I truly believe this they want the
destruction of Florida because they
believe that that would help take out
DeSantis and they think DeSantis is well
basically Trump on steroids uh here's
Joy Reid gloating about Florida being
hit by the hurricane
no shouldn't happen he Marco Rubio and
other tea party members at Senate and
House said they shouldn't have that
money it's too expensive and now as you
said he's now got to go hand in hand to
Joe Biden
for eight it's something he didn't even
believe in as a tea party okay she is an
absolute liar what Joy Reed is referring
to there is that Marco Rubio and
DeSantis and some other Republican
Senators years ago on another hurricane
voted against a bill because they wanted
the bill to just be straight up hey we
are going to give this money to help the
people but what happens in government
you guys all know this is all of this
pork gets thrown in there all of this
extra money on all these pet projects so
that's what Ron DeSantis and Marco Rubio
were trying to fight they wanted to help
the people that were deserving which
hurricane was that for that was for
Hurricane Sandy they wanted all of the
money
to go to New York to go to the recovery
of Hurricane Sandy they didn't want the
pork involved but of course she doesn't
say that right because she's an absolute
liar and a fraud and that's what happens
when you work in mainstream media she
works at a massive fake News
disinformation Network known as MSNBC
Marco Rubio just commented on uh on this
a couple days ago here's from Yahoo news
Senator Marco Rubio on Sunday said he
would vote against a federal relief bill
to assist Florida in recovering from
Hurricane Ian if it contain unrelated
spending projects sure I will fight
against having pork in it that's the key
Rubio said on CNN State of the Union we
shouldn't have it in there because it
undermines the ability to come back and
do this in the future Rubio said that
extra spending would deter other
lawmakers from voting on it we can do it
it's possible to do it without loading
it with all these other things because
otherwise you have you will have people
in the senate in the house that are
going to vote against disaster relief
because they view these disaster relief
bills as ways for other people to get
their pork and pet projects done Rubio
said so that is exactly what Marco Rubio
and Ron DeSantis were talking about
during Hurricane Sandy Joy Reed is an
absolute liar and ever and this is why
everyone hates government why do people
hate government because they lie about
everything and then every time they
supposedly do something good like Hey
we're going to put federal funds to help
people who need it whether it's
Hurricane Sandy hitting New York whether
it's hurricane Ian hitting Florida you
find out oh there's I don't know let's
say 10 billion dollars to help these
people whatever the number is it's
irrelevant but it turns out that they
threw in an extra 6 billion and some of
that's going to Ukraine and some of
that's going here and it's to you know
study transgender uh gerbils and and the
rest of this insane uh nonsense so Joy
Reed is a liar Marco Rubio is doing the
right thing get a clean bill and let's
get those funds there